please welcome owner of the craft studio
and one of my dear friends lindsay
pierce
thank you for having me i cannot wait to
craft with you and with leo this is a
dream come true well when it comes to
representing the younger generation
there's no one that i love to do it more
than with drew crew member and my dear
friend leo kelly
also known as the shirley temple king
and i was just asking you leo what are
you doing for christmas we are going to
sleep over my grandma's house like we do
almost every year we didn't do it last
year because you know covey and stuff
like that and because you know if you
get big presents who knows if you can
fit it in a car but this year we'll make
an exception
i am so happy to hear that you have
these traditions of sleeping over at
your grandmother's house i mean it kind
of sounds like a fairy tale book i agree
it does i agree that sounds mad sleeping
over your grandma's house on christmas
eve while sugar plums dance in your head
that's exactly right
bring out the sugar plum fairies at
grammys i love that oh i love that i
know i want to come
you know uh lindsay owns the craft
studio in new york and that's actually
where i've taken my children since
basically they could walk or move so i
turned to lindsay who's the master so
teach us lindsey what are we making
today i'm so excited this is magic ready
for this leo wet ready drew yeah we're
gonna make surprise balls which are so
much fun because it's a gift that you
get to keep on wrapping unwrapping
unwrapping and who doesn't love
unwrapping the present it's kind of the
best part right is there like
spoiler alert something there when you
unravel yes and they're super fun to
make you guys are gonna love this you
ready leo i can't wait okay okay let's
get started okay so the materials are
really easy to gather okay crepe paper
also known as streamers i always have
leftover from parties that i've had find
that drawer where you have your
streamers if you don't have them you can
get them anywhere and get ready to make
some surprises with them so i like to
start by finding my treasures i want to
put in look oh leo found a lion and a
sloth i have a little husky i mean i i
want to put a couple of these in there
can i do that or am i already messing
this up this is the big kahuna surprise
the first one so can you imagine if you
get to the end of the surprise ball and
that treasure trove is there yeah this
is amazing to me so what you're going to
do is you're going to put it in the
center of the starting point i leave a
little towel
just like this and you have tape next to
you but i honestly just like to wrap
when it's a bigger item like
there you go there you go i'm kind of
flipping it in all different directions
and remember my motto is perfect is
boring and there are no mistakes in art
so we don't want it to be perfect we
want it to be unique and special just
like you two
um okay so now i have my first one i'm
gonna grab my second surprise maybe i
want a little candy treat on this
journey i'm going to add this little guy
because it looks really cool a little
teddy bear okay so now that we've
practiced the wrapping i want to show
you
how you can personalize it and make it
amazing look at drew's i mean i want to
unwrap that that's nice i'm really in my
happy place right now
also there is like so much loot in here
so much loot whoever gets that surprise
is getting the best surprise ever so do
you see my this one in front of me
that's all decorated like mistletoe you
have a cutie little reindeer leo has a
little frosty guy a snowman i love this
too so once you're done and you guys
have a finished one next to you too
that's just without the or how in am i
getting this to look like this lindsay
you are by adding some pizzazz some
accessories okay so you have next to you
a glue gun which everyone at home makes
you use with a grown-up leo be very
careful don't touch the glue or the
point right i'm adding green leaves
i'm adding um some berries and i'm
turning this one into
mistletoe
or holly berries that's awesome this is
the fun part you can accessorize them
love it
also drew i know you love a tablescape
how cute would these be look look at her
go yay
that's amazing
oh hang on a second
mine is sticky oh
i i can't wait i have an idea of what
you're going to do i want to see if
that's what i think
let's see it
there we go i i feel like i need a
little bit of a nuttier dog i like it
does he have google eyes i knew it
i loved it this is cute and i'm proud
of where i got to with it because i was
a little worried at first you had but
now i feel good presenting that to
someone and i know
what's inside and there's a lot of
treats and this was really happy and
joyful and
i love this fulfilling are you in do you
like it yes sir i love this i think it's
a great way i think it's a great form
i'm a present because for example you
know if there's a you're wrapping a bike
you're gonna know what it is
can you imagine a surprise ball the size
of a bike though
i i challenge anybody to do that there's
also um like a little bit of a pinata
like there's so much inside here that
you're not expecting lindsay thank you
for
reinventing the gift wrapping crafting
approach to the surprise ball well
you took it to a whole new level leo
show yours
this is mine hold it up i love it you
guys
lindsay always thank you so much for
making like these wonderful traditions
and tips and tricks to like having a
craftier more colorful
joyful life i really appreciate
everything you put into the world i
appreciate you thank you so much
[Music]